this is a production of Cornell
University
this is a new rangarajan I am the
director of the small farm program and
I'm really excited to share with you
more about the program the kinds of
things that we do and help you
understand a little bit more about the
way we sort of present ourselves in the
world but that's it's led a little bit
of confusion so I'm hoping I can clarify
it so I just wanted to give you first
I'm just trying to advance my slides
there we are tell you about the program
itself and where we sit we are in the
College of Ag and life sciences our
funding comes primarily through small
grants and large grants from the USDA
and we are supported in part with some
funds from the college and through
smith-lever what our goal is and we were
started in 2001 because at that time
around the country there was a
tremendous cry out for greater attention
to the needs of small farmers this
emerged from the famous Pickford case in
which USDA was sued for not addressing
the needs of black farmers in the south
so they committed funding to develop
small farm programs across the country
and that is it's from there that the
small farm program was started I joined
the program as the director in 2004 and
have totally enjoyed myself we have a
really great staff that I'll introduce
you to over the process of our called
our webinar today but share with you
really the kinds of work that we're
trying to do to enhance the viability of
small farms in New York the Northeast
and in fact now we're working nationally
so I think our strengths are really best
defined through the way in which we try
to identify critical issues that are
affecting small farms and their
viability and then how we develop
collaborations to address those issues
we are always thinking about the types
of publications or information
resources that will support small farm
development whether you are just
thinking about farming all the way to
where you've been farming for 20 years
and you're thinking you may want to
restage eyes your business or add new
commodities we try to serve all those
farms either from initial startup all
the way to when they're optimizing their
performance to developing a mature farm
business so we are doing a lot of things
at all of those points but I think we're
probably most known for our beginning
farmer support and so i'll be sharing
with you stuff about that but we do have
a network of educators in across the
state that have committed a supporting
small farm and new farm development and
in every county of the state we have one
individual who's identified and i'm not
sure if any of you are those folks but i
would encourage you to find out who
because we do send resources out to them
and they those educators may in either
in your county or surrounding counties
have other resources locally to share
around small farm development so i just
thought i would back up and tell you
what is a small farm and the USDA
defines that as a farm that has a gross
annual revenue of less than 250,000 a
year this number some people are pushing
on it thinking it should be closer to
350 but this is where we're at right now
and you should know that ninety percent
of the farms in the country and in fact
in New York fit this definition the most
rapid growth in farms at this point are
those firms that are very small that may
be grossing less than twenty-five
thousand dollars a year and this is from
the sort of energy that's been focused
on developing new farms but there's a
lot of people and probably many of the
people that you work with who are really
just growing something in a fairly small
area and selling it very locally and
supplementing their family income and
their own family food security so we are
thrilled and excited to help anyone who
wants to identify themselves as a farmer
and frankly the more people who call
themselves a farmer the better in my
book so what we have observed that most
our farmers are really diverse they are
often diversified vegetable farms are
diversified across enterprises so they
may have mixes of vegetables in poultry
or beef and fruit any combination honey
maple syrup we have folks doing small
scale value added there's a huge
diversity and I think a really
optimistic and positive sense of
possibilities in our small farm sector
so a little bit more from the people
that we actually are able to reach we
have listserv and I'll show you how to
join that where we share updates every
two weeks on important resources or
information that are of interest to
small producers but when we recently we
did a survey because we are trying to
understand more for example about where
do small farmers actually sell their
products and I really sharing this just
again to drive home the point that when
you look at the farm size there are our
majority of them are below 50 acres and
then even the highest percent of the
people that answered our call for
information we're farming less than five
acres and this again maybe many people
you know and you work with and again
that gross revenue quite low the
majority of the people that are
accessing instead of communicating with
us are making less than 25 thousand a
year we do have farms that are making
more than 250,000 a year and so while
USDA may not call them small I think
that we create a home for them and I
tend to use a much more flexible
definition of what's a small farm and I
tell people that if you think you're a
small farm you are and the reason I say
that is it's really contextual and it's
a lot
on your community the people you
interact with and where you go to sort
of find your colleagues and so we have
some farms for example that may
participate in a lot of our programming
that make well over 250,000 but they
align with the values and the sort of
energy of the small farm movement
enterprises based on some surveys that
we've done recently really focused
heavily on poultry and vegetables again
if you are even thinking about starting
a small farm these are the easiest entry
points as well the least amount of
capital required for getting into
production at a more commercial level we
tell people at least ten thousand
dollars and some leased land and you can
and well-drained soil ideally you can
start a vegetable operation so this is
just again to give you a sense of where
we're seeing the energy and the sort of
growth across the state the majority of
our farms have not been in business for
that long and this is part of a result
of our new farm project which has been
really out there and recruiting people
into the program but over sixty percent
of the people that we are reaching our
have been farming for less than ten
years but we do have quite a few that
are what we call the sort of mature
farms over 15 years in production that's
just really I want to just give you a
little background on who we've been
serving traditionally and we know that
that's changing and so we're developing
resources to address some of the changes
in that audience so I and the way that
Laurie and Jen had shared with me some
of your interest is that there may be
individuals you work with it really
would love to scale up a little bit and
maybe add some income to their home and
or their youth and want to start some
kind of a business and experience what
that is to be an entrepreneur and I
think there's a tremendous amount of
energy and excitement in the small farm
sector for entrepreneurs we know for
example
that the interest in local foods is
growing and that there's a demand for
farm products and direct sales every
year it grows ideally we could dream of
25% of all of our food being sourced
locally in time in Tompkins County we've
achieved that actually but where when we
think about the rest of the country
there's a lot of challenges with that
but we still keep working towards it in
New York State there's a growing number
of CSAs in farmers markets I'm sure
you're all familiar with these but one
thing that we've faced with these is is
that just a second that there's some
saturation happening in these markets
and so we have found that some of our
producers are really interested in new
wholesale markets that are sort of like
direct marketing but you're going direct
to a wholesale institution so food hubs
are an example of that some institutions
are really interested in buying direct
groceries like wegmans and others and
the independent grocers are starting to
enter the scene of rhyming to provide
easy to access wholesale markets and
then restaurants which have been a
stronghold for many of our small
producers and so we see that for
entrepreneurs not only developing in and
creating products for direct markets but
also thinking about diversifying their
markets to include wholesale and
different sorts of strategies primarily
to manage risk and to ensure some more
farm security so a lot of our work and
I'll share with you some resources that
are emerging to support both the direct
markets but really the wholesale market
readiness so here is a list of different
things I want to share with you and I'm
going to do this primarily by doing a
tour of the website because if you
haven't been to our website it can be a
little bit daunting
because if there's a lot of information
there but I wanted to share with you
what I felt are really important
resources that you may need to know
about that can support your work and I'm
hoping that we've designed these really
to help educators across the state get
farms to do some of the work on their
own before they start taking up a lot of
your time so keep that in mind we're
trying to help with designing materials
that help you be more efficient to give
you easy to access resources that you
can share with these new farmers or
small farms that might come to you but
then also we want to hear from you what
you feel our resources that you need
going forward because that's where I
think we can do a lot to support your
work so I'm going to ship now to the
website and I hope you can see this can
everyone see this website if you yep all
right great yes thank you so the first
thing to note at our home page and you
can see it's small farms that
cornell.edu is we feature events that
are coming up across the state and so
these events for example co-managing
farm stewardship with food safety gaps
and conservation this is a resource for
example that's been released microloans
grazing methods and opportunity for
learning these are some events or
activities that we want people to know
about I on this page I wanted to point
out to you the strategy to join our list
and so down here in the corner to sign
up for the e-news and we really
encourage folks to sign into this enews
using this template we have a few
questions we like to know and I can even
try to extract from you the number of
people who are gardeners or homesteaders
aspiring farmers that have been
subscribing to us if there was any
interest from you to know who the in
your own county is already interfacing
with us we also are always really deeply
interested and committed to enhancing
the diversity of our audience and so we
really ask in hope that people can share
with us more about their own backgrounds
and we are recently working really hard
to create supportive strategies for
military veterans to come into
agriculture so we asked about if they
can self-identify as a veteran and I'll
share more about that so again from the
home page across the top there's a whole
bunch of buttons here and I'm going to
probe a few of those I'm going to probe
the quarterly a little bit share with
you some more about projects and
resources so if we go if you go into the
resource tab you will find some of our
most popular guides and the first one I
want to show you is this guide to
farming in New York and we develop this
years ago and this is been one of our
flagship publications from the guide to
farming in New York if you get calls
from individuals who are either
interested in farming or have more
questions about business structure
strategy marketing considerations I
would encourage you to sort of spend
some time at this website and see what
you can find here we have resources on
developing a farm for example different
structures and the issues that they are
important and these are all designed all
of these fact sheets are designed to be
either downloaded as a full guide or you
can use them independently and so it
tells you when we've revised it and we
actually when there's new information we
revised every summer and so we have a
whole group of authors that have helped
us with this to revise it so here is an
example of the fact sheet for example on
farm insurance which will tell you the
issues around
having supplemental or product liability
insurance and basically information to
really make sure that small farmers are
considering risk management and how
they're going to protect themselves in
their family so again this is just the
guide to farming in New York has we did
print it at one time and I when we
printed I think we handed out over
10,000 copies and really the excitement
for this came from established farms not
just new farms there is information in
here that any farmer really needs to
know about and so definitely explore
this guide and hopefully you will find
it interesting and helpful and the work
that you're doing with gardeners who may
be wanting to scale up and so this
particular resource is just one of
several that I think are important for
you to know about I'm going to dig in a
little bit to the urban guide in a
minute well actually I'll just do that
right now so the urban guide to farming
we use the same model of the guide to
farming in New York but here we're
focused strictly on in an urban
environment and in this case the topics
are different some are similar but
Madore and we encourage people to use
the general guide as well but here you
may have some specialized issues for
example dealing with soil contamination
so this again is printable as a fact
sheet and you can use this to share with
somebody who's really interested in
doing urban farming or has a concern
about soil contamination there's a
tremendous number of resources that are
linked and we're currently in the middle
of doing a complete update of the guide
and adding a few North more sections the
sections that we want to add our focus
in on mushrooms and agroforestry as well
as some more dive down into hydroponics
and and these new sort of vertical
farming strategies that everybody seems
to be excited about
so that's a bit more about the two
guides to farming these other resources
are the on-farm if you have people doing
poultry this on-farm poultry slaughter
this was driven by a liability insurance
issue where a bunch of farmers were
calling us and saying they do not
they're getting cancelled from insurance
policies and that was a big concern to
us so we acted very quickly to respond
to that working with insurance companies
to create what we felt were guidelines
to support safe handling on farms for
poultry slaughter and because there's an
exemption under a thousand birds we want
to make sure that people are really if
they're doing it on farm that they're
considering all of the components of
setting up a good system that's both
efficient for them for labor and safe
for the quality of the birds they're
producing there's an online course that
complements this and Linda livin has
been a real leader for us and she's out
in western New York and an Extension
educator another important guide is the
guide to direct farming of livestock and
poultry now this is a this is a guide
that's a little bit outdated but Martha
and Tatiana have agreed to help us with
updating this and so we're hoping that
this coming summer we can actually
update the guide but this has probably
been one of our most popular resources
that we produced because there's so many
questions around both slaughterhouses
and processing regulations and then how
to handle and direct market poultry and
livestock so I wanted to make sure you
knew about that and so that really gives
you a few of the overviews as far as
timely information it really is through
I'm sorry I'm trying to get to the page
here it's through our small art our
update and so please do sign up for the
update bigger every two weeks and if you
haven't been receiving them but there's
a ton of reef
sources that we both share on our
website homepage but we also have these
inside in the updates that are come as
an email I'm trying to remember I think
here is the list of the archives under
our news button and so you can see for
example if you open up one of the one
that happened last the most recent one
one of our recent ones it tells you both
different things to be happening at
Cornell different announcements and then
events that people should know about and
then some job opportunities we get a lot
of people sharing job opportunities with
us and then grants and so this is our
way of trying to provide timely
information to individuals who you know
people that are developing their farms
looking for support so again I really do
encourage you to join and get the update
the other flagship publication for us is
our small farm quarterly and so this is
a quarterly magazine and i'm not sure if
any of you have ever written for it but
we would welcome submissions because our
editorial team is made up of mostly you
educators from around the state to help
us and they provide articles or they
recruit writers for the articles this is
an entirely volunteer publication we're
lucky to have a nice partnership with
lead publications who put out country
folks and so we generate all of the
content and they do the printing and put
it in to the country folks as an insert
so it goes to over 30,000 families
across the Northeast but what's exciting
here is that you know anywhere in our
website you can search a topic so for
example if if you are interested in
grazing you could hit that and what it
would do is basically give you a list of
a bunch of the different articles that
we have both in the quarterly
historically this top one is about
grazing online course which I'll tell
you about a little bit more you can just
click on it it will pop you to the
article that was written by Nancy
glazier educator in western New York
talking about renting grazing land and
so this was originally published in the
quarterly but we want to make sure that
all of these are available for folks
going forward and then you can see here
in that same issue there was a whole
bunch of other articles that may be of
interest to you so I think let me just
double check here
so over time we have always struggled
because as I've described small farms
are really diverse and how do you pick
where to sort of focus your efforts and
trying to support the development of
such a diverse sector of our farm our
farming culture so because of that we
have done Oh every other year is we host
what we call a small farm summit and
that summit we recruit broadly across
the state using a webinar type format
and so we'll have up to seven or eight
sites around the state where we ask
producers to gather along with those
interested in their success so educators
we get members of different nonprofits
soil and water and RCS all sorts of
folks would gather in these different
locations and then what we try to do is
really focus on helping them help asking
them to help us prioritize the
directions that program like this should
take and we ask them to gather in
regions because it's really important to
us that we're always cultivating
regionally strong collaboration and so
getting people into the room is so much
more important I think than anything
that we do and that's the hardest thing
in our culture now is to actually have
people feel like they develop meaningful
relationships so we have intentionally
designed the summit even though it's
only every two years we're hoping that
we can really help people connect with
those around them that can help we in
2012 we we actually had a survey we had
over 700 small farmers respond to help
us prioritize where they thought are the
real opportunities to enhance the
viability of small farms and the top
five that came out of that was
distribution to reach local markets
figuring out how to do this how to help
small producers no matter the scale
actually get
themselves into local and regional
markets more effectively and more
efficiently economic impact of small
farms on communities this is like a huge
question we have all these small farms
and that are supporting local food and
hiring local kids and and what is the
impact of them on their farms and
interesting I found it really
interesting that this was the second
priority from a farm community helping
deal with livestock processing issues
how do we identify where they should be
and and how do we expand or improve our
access to those processing facilities
financing and then greater investment in
research and extension and other
services so this is just giving you a
flavor of the kinds of information we
get when we ask farmers where should we
focus but but one of the things that I
found really interesting is we asked
farm small farmers you know where do
they see themselves going in two years
as far as the new ways they want to
market and what I want to highlight is
this growth an interest in wholesale and
in two years a bunch of currently the
majority of our farmers are using farm
stands or farm markets and csa's and all
of these you pics as their primary
direct channels in the way that they
share their products but this idea of
failing to restaurants and food hubs and
groceries has really been interesting
and exciting and we have some very small
producers in the state who are doing
this in finding that they're being
really successful so one of the things
that we've done as a program is invest
in developing a curriculum to treat to
help new producers or existing farmers
become more wholesale market ready and
we're rolling this out on April
eighteenth and nineteenth it's a two day
in service your colleagues are the
instructors we have folks from across
the state that have worked with us to
develop this and violet stone in our
program has been leading this effort and
the materials will help
users make decisions on how to shift to
a wholesale market how do they match
their production to the demands of these
markets what's the culture among these
different types of markets and then how
do we figure out how to work together
and foster these opportunities in within
regions so that's just really more of a
teaser and something I want you to be
aware of this is a professional
development opportunity the people that
we want to have a 10-hour people like
you educators around the state who may
be getting these kinds of questions or
anticipate that it may become a bigger
part of their work so just to put that
in mind as you in your planning and if
it's something that's of interest to you
so what I'd like to do now is go back
again to our website and share a couple
of more resources so this is that
wholesale marketing piece baskets two
pallets preparing small and mid-sized
farms to enter food hubs cooperatives
restaurants in groceries and so this is
the basis of it we do have a wholesale
market watch and a lister that you can
sign up and we share information about
that we've also had a series of webinars
that if you're really curious about
understanding what small farms are
interested in this I would encourage you
to go and take a look at some of these
webinars where different farmers have
shared with us their transition from
direct to wholesale and you would be
surprised how small some of these farms
are and so we have a big group of folks
and this is a group of your colleagues
that have been helping to write this
curriculum so stay tuned I and hope it's
something that you would might be
interested in going forward so there's a
few other things that are happening at
the program and what are other areas
that I can't really dig into with you
right now but I just wanted you to know
about our we have a whole new effort
focused on helping farmers who are
interested in grazing
and so we have a grazing initiative and
we also have a program that's focused
quite heavily on tillage and soil health
management for small producers so those
are two projects that are really
specific and really focus on a
particular sector and we do take these
things on periodically I want to focus
in on the our beginning farmer project
the Northeast beginning farmer project
so this actually emerged from all of you
in 2006 we kept getting we started
having conversations with educators that
we were connected with and and and they
kept saying you know I can't believe the
number of people coming to me with
interest in starting a farm and I don't
know how to respond and then what we
observed is that everybody around the
state was so busy creating their own
curricula and trying to put together our
own materials and it seemed like kind of
a crazy waste of a lot of people's time
to not have a centralized resource and
so that's when we really brought
together a team of educators and created
the beginning farmer project our vision
is that every new farmer in New York has
access to the support information and
training they need to be successful like
that's our mission and we wanted to be
that anyone who wants to farm regardless
of where they're at can do this and have
people that can help them with it so in
order to do that what we have really
done in worked really hard as I
mentioned is create small farm and
beginning farmer contacts within every
cce office around the state and we are
welcome to add you to our list online of
references at our home page there's a
who can help tab and you can and we are
happy to make sure that you're listed
there we've also in our work cultivated
a network of organizations in New York
and the Northeast is specifically
support new farmers so it's not just
extension educators that are out there
doing this work we have a bunch of
nonprofits we have incubator farms
we have all sorts of people that are
really passionate about helping people
start farming and so what we try to do
through the small farm program is
professional development for those
individuals to try to make sure that out
the educators and those that are
supporting you from development really
have connection to the best resources
information materials to make their jobs
easier so we really do see ourselves
both this we provide information and
resources directly to new producers but
then we want to cultivate a learning
community among the educators that are
working in this area and so we have met
annually we call it the beginning
farming Learning Network and we usually
meet at the century house around end of
October up in Albany because that's
actually six hours from everywhere in
the Northeast believe it or not and so
we have do an in-service training and I
think I don't know if any of you have
been there but it's actually usually a
really dynamic and fun gathering where
we're learning from each other how to do
this work so I'm just going to review
with you just quickly some of the
offerings we have online courses these
are six-week non-credit classes and we
have currently I think we're up to 17
classes we've had over 1300 people go
into these classes and a forty-two
percent report increasing their own
revenue in their farm after taking these
classes and so these are again
facilitated primarily by extension
educators who have developed a passion
for working with new farms the the model
that we're using is that people are
paying for these and we're paying
educators to help teach them and then it
also covers them the administrative
management which is a ton of
administrative stuff that has to happen
behind the scenes with this for Erica
franais and so she's been our real
Shepherd for the online courses one of
our staff members but we are always
looking for new instructors so just so
you know that
and then I'm going to take you on a tour
of some of our rhesus resources on the
website and so let me do that right now
area so the this prop this website
currently is separate from the small
farm program website and that's caused
some confusion the reason we created a
separate website was partly because some
of our funding we needed to have a place
to keep a lot of materials but it also
it it has had such an energy and drive
the development of the beginning farmer
project and the tools and the resources
that it was a lot to manage but i do
want to give you the heads-up that we
are imagining bringing the two sites
back together going forward because a
lot of the new farms that we've been
cultivating are actually hitting the
point where they really are more
established and are going to need a
different kind of support so we are
tooling up for that so one of the things
that i just realized that i cannot get
past this little sharing my monitor
screen okay so i think that this
question about how where do you start
well I guess there's getting started so
these what we have created is this
section called plan your farm and so
this portal and basically collection of
resources is really there to help
someone who wants to work on their own
start to get into thinking about is
farming for me what commodities do I
want to do how am I going to do the
planning for this farm so it's a whole
series of worksheets that you can do
with somebody or you can send them there
and say just start to do your own
thinking and planning and it's done
using a sort of question narrative where
people can actually go through and get
some guidance as to how to narrow down
what do I need to know how do i financed
it where it can I get a grant and so
these are structured as tutorials so for
example in this tutorial on
goals and skills what's really
interesting is we compliment both the
written material with videos of farmers
and new farmers around the country
around the state who really have been
able to clearly articulate some of the
issues and the strategies that have
helped them be successful and so the I
would definitely send somebody to this
planning your farm hub as a place to get
started and one of the challenges I
think that all of you may face is people
you know they want someone to sometimes
hold their hand and I would encourage
you to push back and say show me what
you can do and they yeah they totally I
just see a comment from jen that they
want us to do it and and it's and i
think that you know farming as an
entrepreneur is an individualized action
and starting with information and giving
them we're hoping this portal helps you
say look dig this is your project here's
where you get started and hopefully you
can use some of these you can point
people to some of these resources that
I've shared with you to help them start
thinking about farming but what we know
is you know doing this kind of stuff
online is really in some ways for a
certain kind of learner and we know we
have a lots of different learners so we
have some people that just don't even
want to do online teaching and so we
have encouraged and support and work as
a network of educators around the state
who do these so you want to farm type
workshops and if you haven't done one of
those or you're interested I would
encourage you to go to the who can help
tab here and I and if you don't know who
else is doing it in your area but I bet
you could find somebody locally if
you're not aware of them who is doing
these types of trainings within a
several County area so don't start from
scratch don't feel like if you do this
yourself and if you aren't able to find
someone just send us a note give send me
or Erica an email and we will try to
connect you with people who can help you
figure out how to address this need
so so these worksheets are really meant
to be a self-guided process for planning
a farm startup but I what's become our
real flagship is our online courses and
so we have a whole bunch of online
courses and we're actually going to be
restructuring the way we present them
because there's it's a bit overwhelming
and people are telling us that I don't
know which to take first and I don't
know how to approach it but none of
these have prerequisites their six-week
facilitated courses that help you
understand all the aspects of getting
into farming square one one of our most
popular classes is a very first class
like is farming for me you know what are
your own motivations what resources do
you have what might fit you as far as an
enterprise these are the kinds of
questions that are addressed in square
one and it could be a place where you
direct people who come to you like I'm
thinking I'd like to start a farms like
go do this think go through the process
take this course and then let's talk
after that and so again it's not about
dismissing them but trying to help them
help themselves and so we've structured
these classes to be interactive as a
tremendous number of resources that
people have access to there's often two
people that are teaching together
there's some basics about how this class
is structured one of our new classes
that keeps filling up and its really
interesting is farm scale mushroom
cultivation and Steve Gabriel who's on
our staff now has been teaching this and
every time he's offered it twice and it
fills up each time 50 people and there's
a waiting list so there's a lot of
excitement and interest in something
like mushrooms and whether they're
growing it on logs or they're using
other
other strategies with bags this is a
class that if you it's an unusual class
and it's an unusual crop but we do find
a lot of interest I wanted to make sure
you were aware of that so part another
part of the online courses and something
that's been really helpful I'm just
trying to find them is our voices of
experience videos and so again another
way of helping people learn is by is by
learning stories is by seeing stories
and learning from other farmers and so
we started building this video
collection in 2008 I believe and we had
some funding from USDA as well as from
farm by ability to do this and we have a
whole collection of videos on our
YouTube channel so it's YouTube Cornell
small farms and for example there's I'm
not sure if you can hear this or not but
here's one from Black Diamond these
videos are some of them have been like
this one I'm castrating pigs I can't
believe how many people have watched
this and so but these are some farms
that are in and around ethica but they
represent really diversified farms and
they represent different perspectives on
how how to do the work and so they
include videos about the farmer
themselves sort of how they approach
different activities how they may mark
it and then we have a couple of new ones
at the bottom on draft horses Don Hewes
who's here locally has started the draft
animal power nap network and has been
committed to draft animal work and we
are seeing more and more people
expressing interest in draft animals so
we wanted to connect them to that so
there are so many videos organized
different ways here's just so I can
remember how many videos we have on here
now
but there's different projects as well
in different videos that we've brought
in for example we have a video here on
Farm Service Agency microloans because
there's a lot of people that are
interested in that program to start a
small operation so understanding what
the issues are we've also had a program
for educators that was focused on
cultural competency for new farm
development and we heard from two
leaders to individuals who are leading
local nonprofits small nonprofits and
how they're addressing issues of
diversity in their programming and what
were some of the challenges that they
faced in working across difference so
there's all sorts of different materials
here on the program but I on a small
farm startup as well as you know how to
build hoop houses and just lots of
different things so I would encourage
you to explore the video collection
farming in action so I think then the
other resources that i wanted to point
you to our again on that home page if
you look across the top of this
beginning farmer project there's we've
gone through the tutorials the online
courses there's also then these
resources the videos the guides and then
we have these articles that come from
small farm quarterly but we have wanted
to collect them together in a way that
these articles then represent different
aspects of getting started in farming
and again another way for people who are
interested in just hearing stories and
learn best by stories and so these are
written by a diversity of individuals
some educators some farmers who and then
we have a lot of profiles of new farmers
here at the bottom as well so I would
again consider this another resource to
help you help people think through
whether or not getting into farming is
something for them
and one other piece I haven't really
alluded to it in it too much but there's
a whole bunch of information that is
buried in these sites that we consider
like the farmers bookshelf and these are
links sometimes to online resources or
how to find them but I in both the
beginning farmer site as well as the
Cornell small farm program site you will
find resources tremendous numbers of
resources that are available in the case
of the small farm site this is where we
really try to focus in on resources for
established farmers for example in
production you can see that we have this
wide array of materials that have been
collected together and so these aren't
the only materials out there but there's
a few that we felt were really good or
well done or easily accessible online
again something that you might be able
to use in your own work to share
information with individuals who come to
you directly or even to be able to
forward them to some of these resources
so they can explore on their own so it's
both the learning information but then
kind of the diagnosis and the support
for decision making and I think that's
the piece that's critical for us is how
do you support good decision making on
farms and so some of our online courses
are related directly to decision making
for example we have a course on holistic
management which is the entire framework
for decision making in which you really
consider environment economics and
social goals that you might have as an
individual or a farmer you can apply the
decision making framework to your life
in general it doesn't have to be for
agriculture but that's an example of
something that we feel is really
important it's not just technical
information it's really the how do you
put it all together and how do you put
it together in a way that feeds your
soul fields your feeds your energy and
really place to your skills and so we
try to think about all of that the soft
skills development
the technical skills development but
this whole piece of scale up so and I
think this may be relevant to some of
you is you know we recognize it it's a
real trick to go from you know growing
in a very small scale and then wanting
to really actually change your practices
and move into something at a larger
scale or more commercial scale so we do
have some advanced enterprise online
courses that are designed for supporting
farm diversification well the mushroom
one is one for example but we have a
high tunnel classes starting shortly we
have both vegetable and berry production
classes that are online to give people
to start or deepen their skill sets
around those two production systems we
have a grazing course all of these are
meant to sort of help with the scale up
and we're going to be adding food safety
and even adapting to climate change so
these are some of the courses that were
adding that are really meant to help
deal with scale up and but we are
current poor funding supports also we
have funding from the USDA to help those
individuals who maybe three to five
years in and want to re strategize and
what we're actually doing is helping
farms create what we call profit teams
and these are teams of consultants often
extension educators who they hire to
help them improve their own
entrepreneurship business training and
planning and help them make decisions
really important decisions to grow the
business and so we have funding each of
the farms who participate get two
thousand dollars as a grant and then
they have to commit 500 of their own
funds so they have twenty-five hundred
dollars to work with over 18 months to
pay people to consult with whether
that's a feed a person to help them with
their nutrition plan if it's someone to
help them with their disease management
plan if it's about how do i improve the
quality for a wholesale market it's up
to the farmer what we want to know is
that how they really feel and all we
care is that they find the right people
to help them take the business to the
next level so this is very much
one-on-one consult
and then the other thing we're doing is
developing these sort of intensive
training programs that will be on
scaling equipment this is something
that's really tricky to go from a very
small scale even to move from sort of
less than and a half an acre to 1 acre
25 acres and then to 10 like there's
tend to be breaks they're like well
actually at over five acres and then
over 25 acres I think there's like some
natural breaks in scale that suggest a
scaling up of equipment and what do you
pick and how do you pick it and what's
going to be most adaptable going forward
so our training programs will focus on
scaling up equipment and then the
wholesale market readiness which we
think diversifying markets is really
important as we move into this and as we
see this growth in local foods the last
thing I just want to talk about and in
share with you is this a whole area of
work that we're doing right now focused
on military veterans and its really
trying to create pathways for veterans
to find employment on farms or to
actually start farms so I wanted to draw
your attention to it because I think
that all of you are really out there and
interfacing with a lot of folks and we
are getting more veterans returning from
service that we are trying to help them
integrate back into community and
whether it's agriculture our gardening
or farming we know there's really
meaningful benefits to them to be
involved with this kind of physical work
so i am going to just I can share more
with you but I don't I think i want to
have enough time for conversation but we
have a whole new area of work that's
developing around supporting veterans
and in this August we're going to host a
one-week intensive that's called armed
to farm for military veterans and it
will take place in central New York this
year
was western New York last year at
Central New York this year and then next
year will be in eastern New York so if
you feel people you know people who
might be interested please let us know
and pay attention to our announcements
when they come out so as I start to
close I want to make sure you know the
folks that can help you in the program
we have a really awesome staff at the
small farm program a violent stone who
leads our wholesale market stuff and
general inquiries Erica who's provided
leadership to the beginning farmer
project and online courses Ryan maría he
has facilitated the educator network and
also is really focusing on soil health
management and creating appropriate
technologies for small farms Matt Weiss
he's new to the program and he's leading
our current beginning farmer grant but
also shepherding the veterans work Steve
Gabriel who many of you might know is
that his background and a graffiti wrote
the book forest farming with Ken Mudge
and he's now joined our program and he's
provide he's being the managing editor
of the small farm quarterly and Cathy
pack who is brand new to the program but
is helping us dig more aggressively into
how do we help cultivate local food
systems and networks for farmers to
really grow their businesses in this
area so I think that's really all I
wanted to share with you which is sort
of the program what we're up to and
well you can always reach out to me or
to any of the staff at the program and
just send us an email if you're looking
for something and you can't find it
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell edu